uh so you wrote a series of good tweets
about Consciousness and pen psychism so
let's break it down first you say I
suspect the experience that leads to the
pan psychism syndrome of some
philosophers and other Consciousness
enthusiasts
represents the realization that we don't
end at the self but share a resonant
Universe representation with every other
Observer coupled to the same universe
this actually eventually leads us to a
lot of interesting questions about Ai
and AGI but let's start with this
representation what is this resonant
Universe representation and what do you
think do we share such a representation
the neuroscientist grossberg has come up
with the cognitive architecture that he
calls the Adaptive resonance Theory and
his perspective is that our neurons can
be understood as oscillators that are
resonating with each other and this
outside phenomena
so the course grain model of the
universe that we're building in some
sense is a resonance with objects in
outside of us in the world so basically
we take up patterns that of the
University if we are coupled with and
our brain is not so much
understood as circuitry even though this
perspective is valid but it's almost an
ether in which the individual neurons
are passing on camera electrical signals
or arbitrary signals across all
modalities that can be transmitted
between cells stimulate each other in
this way and produce patterns that they
modulate while passing them on and this
speed of signal progression in the brain
is roughly at the speed of sound
incidentally because the time that it
takes for the signals to hop from cell
to cell which means it's relatively slow
with respect to the world it takes in a
pressurable fraction of a second for a
signal to go through the entire
neocortex something like a few hundred
milliseconds and so there's a lot of
stuff happening in that time where the
signal is passing through your brain
including in the brain itself so nothing
in the brain is assuming that stuff
happens simultaneously everything in the
brain is working in a paradigm where the
world has already moved on when you are
very ready to do the next thing to your
signal including the signal processing
system itself it's quite a different
Paradigm than the one in our digital
computers where we currently assume that
your GPU or CPU is pretty much globally
in the same state
so you mentioned there the non-dual
state and say that some people confuse
it for enlightenment yeah what's the
non-dual state
there is a state in which you notice
that you are no longer a person and
instead you are one with the universe
that speaks to the resonance yes and but
this one with the universe is of course
not accurately modeling that you are
indeed some God entity or indeed the
universe is becoming aware of itself
even though you get this experience I
believe that you get this experience
because your mind is modeling the fact
that you are no longer identified with
the personal self on that state but you
have transcended this division between
the self model and the world model and
you are experiencing yourself as your
mind as something that is representing a
universe well that's still part of the
model yes so it's inside of the model
still you are still inside of patterns
that are generated in your brain and in
your organism and what you are now
experiencing is that you're no longer
this personal self in there but you are
the entirety of the mind on the its
contents why is it so hard to get there
a lot of people who get into the state
think this or associated with
Enlightenment I suspect it's a favorite
training goal for a number of meditators
but um I think that Enlightenment is in
some sense more mundane and it's a step
further or sideways it's the state where
you realize that everything is a
representation yeah you say
Enlightenment is a realization of how
experience is implemented yes so
basically you notice at some point that
your qualia can be deconstructed reverse
engineered what like uh almost like a
schematic of it what what uh
you can start with uh looking at the
face when you look at your own face in
the mirror yeah look at your face for a
few hours in a mirror or for a few
minutes at some point it will look very
weird and you because you notice that
there's actually no face you basically
start unseeing the face what you see is
the geometry and then you can just
assemble the geometry and realize how
that geometry is being constructed in
your mind
and you can learn to modify this so
basically you can change these
generators in your own mind to shift the
face around or to change the
construction of the face to change the
way in which the features are being
assembled why don't we do that more
often why don't we
start really messing with reality
without the use of drugs
or anything else why don't we get good
at this kind of thing like uh
um intentionally why should we if I
would because you can morph reality
into something
more pleasant for yourself just have fun
with it
yeah that is probably what you shouldn't
be doing right because outside of your
personal self this outer mind is
probably a relatively smart agent and
what you often notice is that you have
thoughts about how you should live but
you observe yourself doing different
things and having different feelings and
that's because your outer mind doesn't
believe you
and doesn't believe your rational
thoughts well can't you just silence the
out of mind the thing is that the outer
mind is usually smarter than you are
rational thinking is very brittle it's
very hard to use logic and symbolic
thinking to have an accurate model of
the world
so there is often an underlying system
that is looking at your rational
thoughts and then tells you no you're
still missing something your gut feeling
is still saying something else and this
can be for instance you find a partner
that looks perfect or you find a deal
when you build a company or whatever
that looks perfect to you and yet at
some level you feel something is off and
you cannot put your finger on it and the
more reason about it the better looks to
you but the system that is outside still
tells you no no you're missing something
and that system is powerful people call
this intuition right intuition is this
unreflected part of your attitude
composition and computation where you
produce a model of how you relate to the
world and what you need to do it in it
and what you can do in it and what's
going to happen that is usually deeper
and
um often more accurate than your reason